I saw you won't leave the club I dashed
her off me and Chase off me like say
you're my girl bro
I Dash to take off me and Chase her out
the door like I said you were my girl
[Music]
a bit worn down and tired today on this
Monday so what we're gonna do we're
gonna start a warm-up exercise the
team's gonna synchronize brav yeah yeah
and we're gonna go R B love songs yeah
yeah okay right I've got a point yeah
and we're gonna go yeah guys get the
lyrics ready we're gonna go Chris Brown
With You Soulful wholesome it's a family
Juicy Lucy little Family Affair okay
right are you ready steady and we're
gonna mix up tempos I'm just gonna Point
Tempo yeah we're gonna mix up tempos
ready three two one uh Hey little mama
oh yeah hot little figure yes you're
ruin and I'm so glad to be yours let's
go you're a class of your own man oh Leo
the cutie
when you talk to me I swear the whole
world stops you're my sweetheart let's
go
I'm so glad that's your mind you are one
of it and you mean to me what else I
mean to you and to get the baby there
ain't nothing we won't do here we go
cause if I got you I don't need money I
don't need cars girl you're my old fam
and oh I'm into you I go oh no what else
would do cause every kiss and every hug
you make me fall in love
no I can't video
with a love
of who feels
hey all right okay well done guys we're
up Round of Applause
let's go ggs we did it we did it we did
it guys now that you've sang along now
that you're active now that you're awake
it's time to get into the IG question
and the question this week was what's
something you did that made you say wow
I can't believe I got away with this and
as per usual guys you guys step to the
plate and gave me some juicy responses
yeah so here we go I slept with a girl's
husband she found out and cried about it
to me I slept with her too oh damn just
consolation nuts I slept with her too
you know male or female
um I slept with it she was a female
that's okay that said this all right
yeah
I've moved to France and didn't pay
taxes for the first five years the admin
is a mess
that's funny that's actually funny the
taxes
that's jokes man said I smoked the Zaza
before me and her parents they thought I
just had a great sense of humor just
laughing
eyes
fair enough
when I gave my mom's brand new Chanel
Number Five to my girlfriend when I was
16.
what
I've literally stolen all food booze and
clothes I've had in the last five months
okay what are we talking about fam what
are we talking about an all food booze
and cloves in the last five months and
gotten away with it from where am I bro
probably not b m or something being a
man stopping to do enough they probably
go all as well yeah all in one yeah
they've got everything yeah yeah yeah
young Wilkos or something whatever yeah
yeah facts uh next paid in a company
work car on my lunch break twice
it's a female that's setting this in as
well
even with James I saw your face like
next
man
that's funny I had a client pay for year
oh wait sorry I had a client pay for a
Year's worth of PT which amounted to 5
200 pounds she only came once
I've had that a few times I had um I
remember I had a PT I had a client who'd
paid me for like six months up front and
then I was leaving that gym oh and we'd
only done like four sessions oh so I
basically said I said to one of the
other PTS
I feel bad about this I said to one of
the other pts I was like bro I'm not
gonna lie to you she's got like
this many sessions left but if you give
her these sessions for free this they
said this chick's got bags bro she's
gonna pay you and he had no clients okay
so he was like bro I'll do it
so I said to her look I'm leaving I'm
really really sorry but I don't want you
to stop your journeys of course you've
started the journey let's not stop the
journey so I'm gonna pass you off to his
name was Alex I'm gonna pass you off to
Alex it's gonna take care of you he's he
knows everything about you I've told him
she was like gang she did one session
with him
text me James I'm really sorry I don't
want to train him accident we did a
session I don't like it oh can I have a
refund blocked a number the money was
gone
I blocked her number my heart was racing
James I had to
I had to
fair you've never told me this but fair
you did what you had to do well when I
was a self-employed PTU I had no money
oh wow bro blocked her number I couldn't
give it back
damn I spent on food oh you I bet you
needed to fair enough food and petrol
Bros sorry G
you know what I've laughed well gone I
remember the time you told us a story
about how
how you had to get to work
darker your calls
oh the other day when I saw the story
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's a run to
work at night right it was dead Bro
you've lived a life my G I lived a
pathetic life you've lived a life my bro
run
flip sake man
Jesus anyway back to it was something
you did that made you say wow I can't
believe I got away with this
I photoshopped my a-level results so my
dad would have whooped my ass that's
Bravada that is incredible bro that is
bravado I could never do anything
because I know it's one of them ones
where he would
probably for one not believe that I've
got these grades and then double check
and come to school yeah to be for your
dad's invasive your dad doesn't follow
normal
times you just said like he just picked
me up at lunch time
that doesn't make sense James he had he
had plans and he was going to act on
those plans he didn't care he didn't
care about the consequences he respected
on Instinct yeah now pops acts on
instincts he doesn't care bro
there's rules bro if I just saw a parent
there at lunch I think where are the
rest of the parents yeah where's mine
yeah 100 wow all right oh I ate chicken
from a garbage at a carnival
yuck what do you mean I can't believe I
got away with this yeah it's not a tree
bro bro yeah
when I went to Estonia two strippers
asked me if I was a footballer I said
yes and got the full works
really
yes I got the full Works no one even
knows what that means but we know what I
mean oh four Works say less yeah that is
a sailor say less
damn that is I can't believe I got away
with that factual that's crazy that's
crazy that is crazy buying child tickets
to the movies for the last 10 years I'm
32 and I'll not stop
okay
did now though you have I don't know
when's the last time you went Cinema
World child tickets the same price as
adults but say wellahi yeah it just says
it there I saw it the other day I was
booking to see something and I just saw
a child and it was like 12 pound adult
12 pound oh raw I was like damn right I
mean it makes sense a chair is a chair
as a chair an experiences and experience
is an experience but I was like damn is
that how they're doing these kids these
kids fair enough
banged my best friend's ex a week after
they broke up he's sitting next to me
right now oh
damn yeah how did you get away with that
what is it with these law I don't know
why is it with these like I'm banging
their friends ex and boyfriends and all
them you're not friends you cannot have
been friends in the first place yeah bro
I would never find any humans goals
attracted up here we heard it they could
be length it's just not on the car yeah
yeah yeah it doesn't exist and then if
she tried it it would put me off more it
would make I would ha I would run to you
I don't think you might get I would run
to you bro also tell me softly
Joey
sit me down
you can't stop because I'm oh I'm
already her as it is a week later softly
tell me like gently bro because there's
only at that point I can imagine yeah
there's only so much my chest can take
yeah yeah and I've already broken up
with the humiliation of she only waited
a week to try and bang you I would I
wouldn't be able to hand I really
wouldn't be able to handle it that's
treacherous Behavior because she wanted
this the whole time factual it was a
plan the whole time yeah I'm I'm a deep
in it now I I really couldn't handle it
I don't think anyone could well clearly
people can but yeah yeah yeah in this
circle
oh God
uh whilst
a thousand times I'm imagining the time
you told me when my little my little new
thing
the my back in the day when I had a I
don't even know you might were here when
I said this story that was back in the
day I would have been there um there was
a chick on Snapchat
I I've never met this girl but she went
to our uni right
she would just send me tits
unsolicited just regular yeah uh and
like you message and I thought it was
just us thing she would just send me
stuff I'm like damn said emojis back and
it was just our little exchange at least
once a week yeah and I was like gang
again and I'll tell him about it and
then he texts me one time
I was like fine literally you'll never
believe you just sent me a nude and I
was like how is it man told me who it
was I got
and I literally felt like I've been
cheated on
I wanted to message her bro
I was I remember what I said to her I
was like are you sure that was for me
she said she never makes she never slips
up in the DMS or something like that I
said wrong
I was heartbroken
heartbroken and
damn yeah
I was a purple tea I tapped it I was in
a gym James I would never forget I was
in Gold's Gym bagging him that's exactly
where I was
oh I was very you told me that because
in my head it's like if we have a cross
path yeah obviously it's on
but she's freeing up to everyone my best
friend of all of all people she's got
options
I know you uh thank you for that never
happens in reverse
never happens in Reverse oh that was too
funny bro okay going carry on all right
I've got a few more yeah
um what's something you did that made
you say wow I can't believe I got away
with this whilst in a sexually boring
relationship I would visit my visit I
would visit my ex at work and have fun
in the back oh my god wow oh my God
that's a young Jin thing that is oh yeah
John yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the next thing
I've stopped paying for drinks when I
use self-checkout Rock I've stopped
paying for drinks when I use
self-checkout she just exclusively
drinks maybe it doesn't ring I know I've
heard that it only rings on like
high-end not high-end foods but all
Foods in general
um and obviously all those things are
like those little things little tags
there's little tags on it but nine times
I said the ticket ring bro oh bro I've
accidentally teached stuff bear Time
same I've I've I think I've paid for
stuff and hellside my hand by mistake
and only do something when I got out I
can't remember what it was question yeah
how much would you someone asked me this
recently how much
um would you have had to like value-wise
how much would you have had to stolen
accidentally to actually make you turn
around and you deep when you get back to
your car to make you turn around and go
back and pay for it value-wise maybe
between a range of 50 and 100 quid it
depends what if I mean like I mean am I
in like uh Asda or something like a
supermarket or I mean like a am I
somewhere else no you're in like a yeah
like a you've just left left like azero
Tesco whatever oh yeah oh they're not 50
it depends
waitrose Sainsbury's you make an okay
yeah
I tell him back I'm already out they're
taking their ring what are we talking
about I didn't do a purpose
I didn't do it on purpose
you man ain't getting that back
I promise you I promise you fame or no
Fame you might not get that
if if I have to use depth perception to
see how far that door is I'm getting a
car I'm not doing it bro I'm getting in
my car at all oh God yeah man they just
have to hold that L on the piano that's
their problem but then when I do in
stocks and thinking oh why is this
missing that's not my content yeah
literally all right a few more
um got caught organizing a threesome
cried my eyes out and swore it was a
joke wow I thought this is I can't
believe I got away with this maybe it
got away with it in the end but yeah oh
wow he suffered organizing organizing a
threesome as a concept it's just bars
threesomes have to be like organic yeah
yeah it has to be organic yeah
organizing one yeah that's no and your
girl catches you
with two strangers oh God right oh bro
it was a joke so why are you crying
facts facts oh God my mate asked me for
eight my mate asked me for an 80 pound
double shot of whiskey at the bar I got
him JD he didn't notice the difference I
pocketed the change oh he paid for
himself that's [__] up
if I'm giving you 80 pounds get me my 80
pound drink
you gotta know the difference though bro
you clearly don't know what you're
drinking he was drinking [__] fam I
remember once I mean run out I had JD
and Coke in this hand Malibu and Coke in
this hand unless I was twisted you
didn't know which one didn't know the
difference bro remember that he was gone
I was wasted he was gone
you could have taste the difference
because they were rum and whiskey bro
well uh yeah I got it with coconut Ramen
whiskey I couldn't smell it or taste the
difference wow I was gone wow bro so you
had I was gone that's the day you called
me cheated
Tuesday night carries I couldn't believe
what I saw in the first year of uniu man
that was the same day bro I told you I
was gone oh I was I've never been so
disappointed
I couldn't believe it I didn't think it
was a thing 18 years old I didn't know
which way was up I didn't know cheating
was a thing bro neither did I until
until it sat in your lap fam until it
literally sat in your lap she took my
hand
put it on her body and said does your
girls feel like this no she never yes
she did that's treachery it's
treacherous but I never heard stuff like
that before 18. I'm solid
what I was a boy
right now for girls
don't ever speak about my wife I thought
you just think you are
don't ever speak about my wife like that
get your hands off me is your girl's ass
squishing like they're like Gap get your
hands off get your hands off
get off me
get the [__] off me get off me man
yeah why is the sweet ladder
where's srilada
Trump
but yeah 18. I was a boy oh my God I was
used to begging for Tom yeah so when
when I'm saying I've got a girl I've got
a girl yeah and he's grandma and put on
the cheeks he said that's her [__]
like this does it feel like this Jesus
Jesus
that's a realm under the [__] yeah bro
I didn't I literally didn't know stuff
like that existed yeah and when I say
literally I mean literally I know bro I
know because I was dumbfounded yeah I
remember when I caught you walked out I
was dumbfounded I was done with the
whole night James
I saw you walk leave the club I dashed
off me and Chase off me like say you're
my girl bro
and Bash to take off me and taste her
the door like I said you were my girl
baby come back literally baby bro
to be 18 again I was in a whirlwind of
emotion Jesus Christ that's too funny
Ren was lips in his thing but I don't
doubt that yeah I don't you were jealous
I couldn't breathe yeah I couldn't
breathe from I remember but yeah I was I
was I couldn't taste the difference
that's hilarious I couldn't taste the
difference and I couldn't see the
difference between right and wrong and I
know oh it was an unbelievable night
care is on a Tuesday went off in
Coventry wow wow I remember holding on
to a
um I think they had like a an elevation
bit like a stadium bit they did yeah and
I remember it was the first time I think
frisky drops tiny Temple yeah fam it's
so funny because I was I was
um literally as you were talking I was
like yeah yeah because that one he was
in his bag he was in his bag wow I was
like wow yeah yeah we were we were doggy
into uh to all of it yeah of course
everything of course we
you know
it's one of them ones oh what can you
teach me how to Deck
the cat daddy as well
wow so I'm gonna do my doggy right I
wanna call you new drug please uh um
it wasn't a new joke boys it was uh boys
new boys I think new boys yeah yeah well
we've gone off topic can we have reread
wow we really have sorry guys um I've
got a few more yeah yeah I'm not gonna
read the title again
um I pushed the raw I pushed a
wheelchair bound guy out of the line in
KFC and blame the person behind me
my mind said a while ago away with this
raw Jesus sold my dad's car for Beyonce
tickets he believes it's still in the
garage
huh what do you mean you don't know what
do you mean I don't know where my car
actually is
this is why this is why some parents
trust their children with [__] way
too much he thinks it's in the garage
I'm not giving my car to my child to put
it in the garage
he thinks he's still in the garage
that's mental I changed the sacramental
wine with lean
lame
like like pop
[Laughter]
like coffee medicine yeah
that rendered me breakfast
oh
[Laughter]
last but not least my boyfriend believed
my boyfriend believed he left hickeys on
me they were from my sighting
treacherous don't let me put my mouth on
another man's mouth
[__] facts wow treacherous yeah and
make me believe it's mine maybe leave
I'm doing a bit so I slips in your neck
and it's next man
I can't even pop a blood vessel oh
goodness me that's crazy but yeah
welcome to the show guys welcome back
guys thank you for that
um you already know the drill I feel
like I haven't said it in a couple weeks
but if you are watching on YouTube
please subscribe to the channel not
gonna push it any further we already hit
the Millie
do what you want to do I lie guys if you
enjoy this show if you care about this
show if you are locked in and you want a
little bit more you want to see the the
Grassroots you want to see the come up
head on over to patreon.com shits and
gigs and please contribute a very very
humble three pound amount of Tempe a day
you need to run the P to SMG and
industrate yourself into the cult babies
okay we've got a lot of big stuff coming
up we've got the second half of our tour
we've got After parties we've got merch
drop in in the next couple months we've
got all this cool cool stuff so if you
want an extra episode every week if you
want first dibs and all that and if you
want to join our pop in Discord Channel
head on over there and get yourself
involved okay finally if you are
listening on any of the podcast apps
Spotify uh Apple like you know what it
is
please please please please please
please please leave us a nice review it
helps the show grow and you know your
boys need that cake facts we need that
cake we've started this journey now
we've got expenses every month we have
just houses and cars and jewelry habits
and they all need fun and they need
consistent funding this cart this
lifestyle can't end yeah it turns out
you can't just buy stuff and then have
it yeah you have to maintain it and you
have to also maintain another thing
that's important to us appearances these
haircuts ain't cheap they're not they're
they're consistent they're consistent
first of all we want haircuts every week
facts the beard needs trimming every
week facts and your boys can't go to any
barber shop we want Donny's to come to
our yardstack stuff like that isn't
cheap so please tell a friend to tell a
friend to watch or listen to the show so
live vicariously through us and watch us
do rich guy stuff
and yeah you can just be our friends
through the screen yeah yeah yeah
because someone at the end of the day
someone needs to live the rich guy
lifestyle and it might as well be us
facts facts anyway we're just being
stupid thank you guys
um I'm excited for this one Believe It
or Not we've got top five no we do have
top five gang right guys let's do it
right guys uh top five top five top five
today
um and as you said before yeah um game
franchise so can you guys list me the
top five gaming franchises of all
top five gaming franchises of all time I
thought we did this already oh no we did
highest grossing we did highest gross in
games yeah
oh yeah I remember
and he says grossing again
yes highest grossing game franchises of
all time all right I'm not 10.
cool
um obviously there's no order of five to
one or one to five so um uh Ellie since
you unlocked in first can I have your
five please yep so we've got Grand Theft
Auto
that's what's good yep I was gonna write
that and I flipping forgot it was in my
head to write and I flipping forgot to
write it and then it went out my head
and I've written other stuff and as soon
as you said the first word I was like
bro you were literally gonna write that
[__]
fax vex vex
um Call of Duty FIFA yep The Last of Us
and Sonic
and what sorry and Sonic Sonic yeah you
were next
um I have oh [__] oh
I just realized what I should have said
yeah very good
um GTA FIFA Cod uh Halo
and they like the Sims
good shout out good Shout good Shout
I've done FIFA Cod Super Mario
Pokemon
and League of Legends
it's one game but it's a franchise to
him it's a franchise to him you know let
him have it right I'm gonna I'm gonna
give you
top seven all right that's what the list
gives me okay number seven
is FIFA
damn
okay I was counting on that sword SP
number six
Super Mario oh no so close
you're good in the tie break though in a
tie breaker I didn't get GTA bro I ain't
gonna be no tie break for me number five
GTA
livid
absolutely level about that
number four
Cod yes
number three
Pokemon
oh wow he's back in the race
number two
Tetris I was I was thinking about Tetris
I was thinking about Tetris yeah
number one controversial
Mario
I'm done
you said Super Mario they're two
different franchises yeah no they are
they are I did think that one well I
didn't think it was no I just meant
Mario bro like Mario caught a Super
Mario audempting there Mario that's not
fair bro Super Mario is just it's still
in the top 10 but it's not in the top
five
but I don't know the difference what's
the difference Mario Super I I
personally don't know the difference I
have Mario but there's Mario Super Mario
Super Mario is like further further on
that was like DS wheat Mario's jump
like early Mario
yeah
early yeah like um Nintendo 64 I think
it was right like original that's the
original version
Mario Kart the Mario Kart is is part of
Super Mario I think oh I think Mario
Kart is under Super Mario
I'm talking about Mario and Super Mario
those are two separate franchises oh
okay I had Mario Kart in my head so all
louder then I'll stop my argument cool
it's cool
um uh so points wise uh Jimmy Two
REM 2
LS2 yeah [__]
oh does that mean I win why would it
mean you win if you they all got two
because I was number six oh yeah [__]
I was thinking yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah sorry yeah
actually yeah because you got number six
yeah because FIFA was the one below yeah
people was seven yeah and then yeah six
words yeah [__] yeah you got it yeah
yeah you got it yeah I said that
official scores are Ting yeah that was
top five star five star Five Guys right
guys let's take a very very very very
very very quick break to shed some light
on our friends over at man escaped
ladies listen close are you ready to
make the men in your life a beach ready
and turn their grooming game up a notch
this summer give the gift of the beard
hedger come on the beard hedger Pro kit
from manscaped
with this game changing tool that can
shape their beards like true beach babes
and make heads turn wherever they go you
might want not want that you might want
that I don't know is your relationship
visit
manscape.com and use the code it says
sng that's sng Sierra November Golf and
enjoy 20 off and for free ship shipping
surprise your favorite guy with the
Ultimate Grooming upgrade and show them
some love with you guessed it manscaped
right guys let's get back to the episode
thank thank you very much well I did
want to quickly touch on before we crack
up or what were you gonna say you want
to say something nothing oh I want to
actually talk about I want to talk about
on this episode the bear oh yes James
yes REM Ellis World cult babies
this is no exaggeration yeah I genuinely
think
season one of the bear might be the best
television I've ever watched yeah yes
bro it's banging a lie I've ever watched
like I I was so engulfed with bro and
obviously this is more because of the
experience I've had in the kitchen or in
the restaurant Alice would understand
yeah
um it's
accurate to a [__] team I swear if
you work in a busy ass bit accurate to a
t the relationships the um the way they
form the way they um arguments split up
on all the sections in the kitchen
everything bro everything about that
show pull up for me real quick so I can
see the characters names everything in
that show
was absolutely fantastic it's an
unbelievable show unbelievable I'm so
happy that I didn't watch it season one
and I had to wait and then watch season
two I binge that [__] in I think two
days season one and season two I
finished a whole tick yeah I've been
season two in one day the whole thing
one day Richard is his name Richie my
cousin the cousin yeah yeah everything
his character development is might be
the best I've Seen On TV bro wait till
you see his character development in
season two right I've just said to you
I've seen it oh sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
I said sorry he's yeah his development
is season two his character development
is the best I've Seen On TV it's amazing
I can't believe it yeah yeah fantastic
bro when he went to stash at the thing
amazing
um hit that I could have won the four
episodes of that yeah just him yeah yeah
it was gas that he was so gassed that he
gets it yes fam and when he when he when
he got back to um bearing said don't
worry I get it yeah said Thank you thank
you bro like wow bro this is TV bro the
whole like everything when
um when Richie went to Stage yeah
unbelievable yeah when Marcus went to
Stage yeah peaceful Serenity yeah the
way homeboy was just like wrong again
yeah wrong again worse again just bang
yeah compose Yeah Yeah clean you bro oh
bro so so so so so through our ups and
downs Sydney's prefer Sydney a season
one then season two
she Jarred me in Season Two Season Two
she I think I think she was kind of the
same for me like she it's she's an All
or Nothing type of woman and yes it has
so many Pros but I feel like she butts
heads with so many people making it
Cottons obviously but I think I think
her I think the way she handles
um them going under in season two
towards the end or when they actually
opened their spot
um the way she handed that was cool was
good yeah it was good and I love when
Richie took over the Expo yeah yeah it's
my favorite thing in the world Expo is
my if if you're in your it looks like if
you're on a roll your dick will be hard
Expo is my favorite thing because people
don't understand what people don't need
to understand that's the whole point of
Expo
people so first of all let me sit
probably because I'm excited to hear you
speak
no because you don't understand at the
past because I was watching him do it
like a composer yeah and I remember
thinking this is like from my
perspective this is in the zone yeah
this is art form yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's no
other way to describe it in the sense
that you are the conductor of this whole
thing because the kitchen clearly fell I
always suck as we say I said we people
say in restaurant you sink so if you're
sinking if you don't have a strong Expo
one food is not going out on time and
that then affects it's it's kind of like
a balloon Theory you have to keep all
the balloons in the air to make a
restaurant float and if one balloon
Falls it's affecting the flow of every
single thing else you know what I mean
talking daddy so
I'm sorry I'm so turned on right now I
have no idea bro when you man watch this
yeah you have you got I can't explain
how excited I'm to just hear you keep
talking about this
you have to you have to have a plan and
you have to have
um you have to have a good relationship
with the person that's on the other side
of Expo IE the head chef or sous chef or
whatever so for example like obviously
you've seen the show if there's so many
checks or let's say there's 20 checks on
and the chef just needs to concentrate
it's all on Expo the chef because the
chef gets tickets as well as Expo get
tickets so there's two tickets on either
side so we can both like match what
what's going on what's getting sent out
and blah blah blah but if the checks
keep running the chef isn't going to
read the checks anymore because the chef
needs to help the rest of the kitchen
yeah yeah so it's down to expert or me
or whatever's on there and I'm the one
conducting this whole [__] I'm the one
making sure that every table has food a
specific amount of time and that in
itself if you if you fell off I failed
as Expo the restaurant fails my bro oh
wow the restaurant fails because
you need to understand that if I'm the
head chef or if I'm the head chef the
person on grill isn't reading every
every check yeah yeah they're just
focused on how many Grill [__] they need
to grow yeah personal salad is only
focus on the salads they need to do
desserts Etc but for me I'm focused on
everything yeah yeah so if I'm if you
man are asking me for all day I need to
let everyone know that I need I've got
six chickens what the [__] does all day
mean so all day means if you look at the
check if you look at all the checks
let's say you've got 10 tracks on on the
on the pass and the kitchen is at a
point where it's done probably its first
turn so every table has food on table
but it's slowly starting to get busy and
people are forgetting [__] because new
checks are coming hmm head chef will ask
or one of the chefs will ask can I get
all day on grill so you need to check on
all the checks how many chicken beef or
whatever that goes on the grill is for
that Chef to make so if you would say
Chef you have six fillets two Ribeyes
and three chickens to make all day so
he's gonna know what he's got to do for
these 10 checks and all they can be for
any subpart in the in the kitchen or in
the restaurant so you can do all day veg
all day sides all day Meats all day
Sushi whatever so that's what all day
means and what is all this like two plus
two and all this kind of [__] mean what
do you mean two plus two no like uh
every okay caveat everything has
different things it's different ignore
me then what do you keep saying sorry I
didn't I really don't want to interrupt
the problem so sorry
every restaurant has different ways of
before performing Expo depending on how
I'm preparing on what they sell and how
their style of service is all right so
that makes sense so Expo is very very
very very pivotal in a in a um what's
the word I'm looking for in a small
plate mix in restaurant dining stuff as
opposed to start as amazing yeah so
because different food goes to different
tables at different times of different
days so that's yeah bro Expo is the one
if you're the conductor and Expo if
you're really good at Expo I think
that's that's what spun me into knowing
that I could be good with what I do yeah
yeah when I first started my
um when I started my management training
going from a bartender to a manager Expo
is one of the things you have to do you
have to do X where you have to do
kitchen you have to do bartending on
something else when I went on Expo that
was when I was like oh I'm in love with
this [__]
the satisfaction you feel of clearing
that last check after a busy Rush yeah
15 minutes yeah but that 15 minutes
could feel like an hour yeah that could
be the best or the worst part of your
day yeah yeah you don't have a strong
Expo or strong beat or strong runners or
a strong kitchen my bro balloons need to
be up the balloons need to be up because
if Expo dies the best way to do it is
speak to the person the managers
floating the floor and say this table
this table and this table needs to be
touched let's get them some drinks let's
get them some nibbles so that [__] up
whoever's on stars for example let's say
you've got five checks of starters or
five checks or five checks or whatever
and each check has three different Stars
if you're trying to touch those three
other tables that are behind you need to
know the starter man make three x just
so we can put it on this table so that
puts him behind you see what I'm saying
so all balloons need to be up for a
restaurant to Runway bro
it is stressful but once you understand
the system and once you understand your
role and your job it's poetry yeah I bet
poetry that's why I was so invested in
that show I'm the best shows ever won
yeah bro in my entire life I I'm not
even privy to all that [__] that you're
talking about and I love it in my entire
life that's what it is I loved it bro
like the different Dynamic of
personalities and the temperament yeah
and like and that's exactly what it's
like bro it's mad and like call me
not even critique really but one thing I
was like guerning for in season two was
watching Kami do his Ting we didn't see
him do his thing at totally season two
that's the reason why I said I prefer
season one season yeah because they were
all in the kitchen in season one yeah
yeah season two was the transition to
the transition yeah yeah just building
the restaurant we didn't get to see Kami
do his thing at all yeah I'm hoping in
season three there has to be season
three the way they finishes season three
I'm hoping we get to see him in his bag
in his absolute element because I'm
trying to think what else could go wrong
do you remember in season one where I
can't remember something happened and
the next day they got pork or something
and it was it's a beef restaurant
that happens every single day that's mad
and I feel like
I feel like they made a really good
depiction of what a regular kitchen
looks like because it was so
Multicultural so many different
personalities and how they the
relationship between Sid and who's the
Latina lady again
um
obviously the only two women in the
kitchen at the time and you could see
like the bicker in between them at first
to how much love they have for each
other now do you know I mean it's just
nail on head my bro bro guys this is one
of the best shows I've ever watched bro
is sick I don't think you understand
how warm I felt on that Richie starch
episode bro
I don't think you understand he found
his purpose he he found his purpose
finding my chest like the same purpose
purpose he found as well this sorry too
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna use that
yeah yeah yeah you man the best stop
don't be right back bro the best so bad
so good I love it when I say I've been
season two in one day it's the best show
bro it's the best shot I loved it wow
yeah the starch thing when when Rich was
actually talking to the guests and
making everyone laugh feeling
comfortable like this is my house fine
and he had the interview with that chick
and she said she's not it she's not it
she didn't turn the thing the napkin
yeah yeah yeah I was like you yes yes
yes because I would have known that
straight away that would have [__] me
off yeah yeah
wow such a great show I'm sorry in that
um since the season two's dropped yeah
there's like these tight white t-shirts
sold out everywhere yeah the ones that
Kanye West sold out everywhere yeah
everyone wants that Vibes
and you know what it resonate with me
because like
I am like this is one thing that like
you see how you just said it truly
depicted yeah how you feel about um the
kitchen and it's like the best thing
you've ever seen yeah
comments in the finale Commons breakdown
of his relationship affecting his focus
and his drive and his dream is me to a t
um
when I'm not performing yeah and when I
have a focus and I want to achieve stuff
and [__] starts slacking if I'm
see with like same thing with the the
balloon thing that you're talking about
is how I get with this team okay so if
I'm
um like for example when my phone was
broken yesterday yeah
I assumed there was 900 messages in the
group chat that I I'm not privy to Clips
aren't getting uploaded to tick tock
this is not happening and this is going
to be messaging me asking me for
approvals on this and the other and none
of it's happening I'm just sat there
like yeah so when he had the breakdown
of just like I don't want happiness I
don't want pleasure yeah I just want
success yeah yeah and he was just like
all of this is going wrong because I'm
distracted from the goal yeah bro
I don't think you understand
that level of like tunnel vision when I
want to achieve stuff and then once that
stuff starts slipping and there are a
couple things behind and I've said I'm
gonna do this and I'm gonna do that and
people are chasing me and like REM might
be hollering me like oh you've got this
thing or you might be hollering that did
you do that thing and I'm like I'll get
to it I'll get to it I'll get to it and
then Edison might be like oh did you
manage to do this thing and I'm like
I'll get to it I'll get to it flipping
someone else has messaging me like oh
you've got that email because I'll get
to it Megan's message have you got this
and I'm like
[__] and then I start blaming everyone
in my life yeah everyone yeah everyone
I'm like why like do not talk to me I
don't need friends I don't need family I
Don't Need Girlfriends I don't need
anyone like leave everyone leaving the
[__] alone so I can succeed in my life
bro when he was in that fridge having
that breakdown I was like wow
wow it was a good it was a good way to
um it was a very very very good finale
because I generally thought they were
game up so the way it was good to see
that they could separate the two
situations and we could see the
flourishing of the restaurant yeah as
well as his
breakdown yeah the restaurant is bigger
than him yeah I'm better than him yeah
and the restaurant doesn't need him yeah
anybody in his mind his world is ending
because he doesn't know because the last
time he left them all alone there was a
gun in the in the in the dance facts so
walk one do you know what I mean yeah
it's crazy very very and the facts are
the funniest
yeah yeah the fact family yeah
um in the apps have you finished season
two he's almost any of it I haven't
started oh he's not watching any of it
either
oh you just said season one a few
episodes right a few episodes season one
yeah
um I won't spoil it too much but they do
a flashback episode in season two it's
good you won't spoil it too much now I
didn't I'm not bad because I generally
thought you wanted season two because
when we spoke last week you said you
were you were watching yeah the
flashback I was gasping so because in
the first minute because they do it
right [__] it's almost like a field
rep bro they do it in the Pinnacle
moment yeah where you're like oh my God
next episode and there's flashback you
want to dash your laptop yeah I want to
attach my laptop and I was like you're
taking a piss out of me we ain't got
time for flashbacks I was this close to
skip it
we haven't got time for flashbacks bro
very good but then once you get into the
episode wow it's good wow isn't it just
the monkey
Mike and them and when they say mental
health is hereditary you man their mom
and Mikey are two pigs in a pod yeah
they're crazy drinkers yeah yeah yeah
addicts fan the forking
the four thing yeah yeah I don't think
you man will have the patience for that
wow the fork situation was mad crazy I
love like the the mo I think I held my
breath for three minutes straight it was
crazy it was a that whole dinner table
with situation was Sensational yeah
unbelievable the show's [__] good
perfect television the show's perfect I
have no critics or critics critiques
right yeah I can watch it for for a
hundred episodes I love the bear bro I
love it I'm so gassed you watched it
because I remember fishing season one
not even that long ago yeah I know and I
was screaming I know no one was
listening I know I know it's so good
best television I've watched in God
knows
um spot me please I'm so gastier
television bro oh now I see why you want
to wait for this episode to talk about
it now I see bro
the [__] the
that's an episode when he smashes down
that last ticket he's just like let's
[__] go yeah he's a rich he's a guy
that's what I'm saying his character
development is from season one season
two is one of the best character
developers I've Seen On TV yeah because
he is Rock Bottom he is zero to him yeah
he had no purpose no misses he's just
annoying he was jarring and all he did
was swear oh my God yeah bro he has a
purpose now yeah and as you have to
watch oh I'm 100 Disney plus bro Disney
plus you have to watch I'm glad that you
said as well that it predicts it like in
a realistic yeah yeah yeah because like
that's a pet peeve of mine yeah Chef
films where you're just like it's not
what it's not yeah that's trust me bro
wait I can't wait trust the dynamic is
so real I can't wait when they did the
um by the deliver routing the online on
Sydney [__] time oh yeah bro she [__]
up yeah oh my God yeah season one yeah
that was that was terrifying
who came into his own and was like my
secret like favorite like guilty
pleasure in the bear in The Bear is um
Sugar's husband
oh towards the end farm when he was
trying because he gets he's a door mat
through the whole show everyone he's it
does everyone including me yeah and the
last episode I'm gonna chat to the mom
yeah yeah he couldn't contain it he fun
couldn't contain it she was I can't take
it what do you mean you can't take it I
was thinking the love of my life and
like my pregnant wife is sat in there
waiting for you you need to get the [__]
in there now you're killing her get in
there and then you have to go back in
their face and just never mention that I
saw your mom outside bro he was crying
oh bro he loves us so much and when he
accidentally told her about the baby as
well
the mom was like raw I can see the
I can see why my kids don't talk to me
you know I mean that was a realization
facts when um when Carmi was like and
the flashback was like this is literally
why I didn't want to come home and my
mom was like what the [__] and Michael's
what the [__] why would you say that so
good bro and um even in season one we're
doing the flashbacks of him in his
Michelin star restaurant oh are you and
the guy was born terrible so slow so
slow you're a joke why can't you do this
you're so slow can you go any slower bro
like you're so slow you can't do this
you can't hack it and he's just ignoring
him like just cracking on
they break him down in that show bro
they break him down and he's like this
they tease you and tease you and tease
you like they say they want it to be 10
seasons bro they do not let you see him
in his bag they don't it's two seasons
and they've not given you a full episode
I've seen him he's not sourced I mean
he's not sourced anything and it's just
like they make him out to be the world's
best chef he made a sandwich in season
one and in season two Sydney said that's
still the best thing she's ever tasted
do you remember that's the best thing
you don't remember I don't remember
Sydney and Marcus were talking about
like the best food you've ever had when
they both left
um and Marcus is it Marcus yeah Marcus
said to Sydney oh you didn't tell me
what your favorite thing was or what
your favorite dish was and he was like
it was chefs it was chefs undeniably it
was chefs and the only thing to my
knowledge that he's made in the two
seasons is that sandwich oh they're
teasing man season one they're teasing
man season three it has to be the way
they've built up season three I
guarantee we're gonna get at least two
episodes of him in his [__] bag yeah
I think season three might be the finale
I think it should be yeah I think you
should yeah I think pacing wise I think
it should be because yeah yeah they're
gonna be season three has to be about
them trying to get start
um
has to be about them trying to get Sarah
and just seeing and I think there's
going to be a big
a big drama between Kami and Sydney
in terms of the partnership partnership
and his focus and all of them things
there because I think season three is
going to be locked in and he's going to
probably want to try to take and forget
he's got a sushi Sam he's gonna yeah
yeah because they're supposed to be like
fully both head chefs right Partners
yeah full Partners yeah so she's
supposed to have equal thing on the menu
equal input in the menu he has equal
input in the menu and already in season
two she she drafted up a whole venue and
he was like scrapped up all of that this
is the menu I spoke to my girl and this
is what she told me to do basically yeah
this is the menu bro oh man wow what a
show um also caviar but also very very
very
um important information from season two
is now back in the UK
from from season two years
now in the UK on Prime it's on
[Music]
this has been a week for me for
television guys I smashed Dave I smashed
the bear I smashed that breathing thing
um yeah and now I'm gonna smash from
oh yes anime and stuff you you anime
obviously I told you I finished dma say
a couple weeks ago
um I've not really watched I've been
watching bleach week by week same it's
great you've seen the next recent
think so three yeah episode three jjk F3
oh I haven't started education I'm
letting it I'm learning to cook
yeah
yeah no no it's it's what it like it's
not crazy but when I say you've never
seen Gojo in the States oh I swear I've
seen like a minuscule clip on Tick Tock
and I scrolled immediately passed it but
he just looks you see how he's like very
composed and chill he just looks on
stuff brother Gojo episode three
um
really this you see stuff you wouldn't
expect
you see stuff you wouldn't expect I
really really want to watch the movie
again you know the movie was [__]
fantastic I saw it twice in a week yeah
bro it's amazing wow I loved that movie
yeah yeah zero whatever it's called yeah
oh my God what movie movie
yeah [__] damn bro
yes right
um trash news Ram
yeah boy so Terry Crews opens up about
his porn addiction effect in his
relationship with his wife and kids
I would be angry at them for forgetting
in the way this is uh in the way of what
him watching porn bro I think so wow
this is um this is a surprising that
this is um something that is still
getting spoken about because he opened
up I first heard about his porn
addiction I've never heard of ice
if you've spoken about it
um he's touched on it a lot at first he
was on uh Tim
um Tim Ferris flipping out thanks man uh
he's on Tim Ferriss podcast literally
when I was still working at David
Lloyd's I'm talking like five years ago
okay uh and he was talking about his
porn addiction okay and how he's ruined
his relationship with his wife
um oh mad but I'm assuming it says he
went on armchair expert
uh which is another popular
um
I can't ever read podcast yeah yeah yeah
so so it says um what the White Chicks
uh actor revealed how he would purposely
start an argument with his wife Rebecca
King so she wouldn't ask any more
questions while he was battling the
addiction poor woman he said it was
horrible my kids and I would uh would be
angry at them uh for getting in the way
Cruz then reflected on his childhood and
spoke about how he grew up in an ultra
religious household and how his father
would how his father was such an abusive
man he went on to explain that he first
was exposed to porn when he was eight
years old which made him forget all the
stress all the problems everything I bet
eight years old furthermore the actor
spoke on how when he was younger he felt
like pornography was just an escape
but as he became an adult he realized he
had an addiction
damn I love this I'm in hotels I would
be on porn channels I would feel super
guilty and then I would read a bunch of
self-help he said damn dude explaining
that his mindset was okay to let me get
back to to even here I felt bad about
myself all the time he said I'm a
failure in my head
yeah Terry Crews is a bit of a weird one
you know like he's spoken about this
bear over the last few years he's also
spoken about like his abusive dad lows
over the last few years obviously spoke
about that time a Hollywood agent grips
his tool that's the only one I know
about yeah yeah he said One agent pinned
him up against the wall grabbed his tool
yeah and he called it like he said he's
like I was sexually abused or whatever
sexual abuse it's technically is sexual
abuse yeah a lot of people that was a
guy
basically what he was trying to say is
that the power Dynamic made it more
sexual abuse in that this guy apparently
is like a big big big agent or either
agent or producer I can't remember uh
and like he's the kind of guy that can
shut your career down so he was he he
was basically saying it's like a a
Weinstein thing yeah which happens a lot
in that kind of thing yeah it's a bit
mad
um so he was saying he's but yeah you
can see you see a club of the um
a lot of comments are just like bro
you're an attention [__] why was this
needed to say out loud yeah it's like um
it's one of them ones that people are
starting to cuss him now because he
speaks about this kind of stuff so much
and I guess it's a weird one because
yeah I guess he's just trying to bring
awareness to it maybe but at the same
time yeah it's been when I say he's been
talking about it for years maybe I have
one time I've never heard so this is new
information to me the only thing I've
ever heard about Terry Crews was the
sexual assault thing yeah that's the
only one I've heard about Terry Crews
but this whole porn thing is is crazy to
me and I feel like
I'd have I feel like it's a bit
harsh to
for people to be saying your attention
seek or whatever if he's trying to raise
more awareness about what he's battling
as opposed to that's do you know what I
mean really [__] move to do that that's
a [__] move like if he's going through
something mentally and he's in the he's
he's obviously at a position and has a
platform where he can speak to many
people or be invited to shows to speak
about himself therefore speaking about
his brain so
I just don't think it's fair for them to
say that like this is I mean nine times
out of 10 most comments aren't fair and
it's one of them ones where he's on a
podcast is the guy's asking about it
um and he's talking about it like if you
don't like it just turn it off
um facts but yes it's uh
it's a tough one man like and I'm
assuming that's still his wife now yeah
um so I'm wondering like what's the
dynamic with like just an embarrassment
thing
because like for me for me personally
let's say my wife was a sex addict and
she cheated on me all the time and she
was famous
if she felt the need to like come out
and tell everyone
and see how like you get off her chest
and raise awareness
I'm gonna be a bit like oh God but like
fair enough like tell your truth if
she's still doing it five years later
I personally might be like
babe like
the first time we brought it up is
actually been long enough now for
everyone to forget it even was a thing
and it's been half a decade and you're
still talking about it it's like from a
close-knit perspective yeah like you're
embarrassing me and the kids every
single time you talk about this that
makes perfect sense like have you not
spoken about this enough by now okay
that makes perfect sense yeah um because
I know a lot yeah a lot of people say
like bro you're a shame in your family
the more time you bring this up because
like yeah you've been speaking about it
for years and years and years
um so it is like a double-edged sword to
be fair does he still act or does he
just do like America's Got Talent or
whatever oh probably I don't know I
don't know the last thing you acted in
but he said he's been battling with this
all his life right yeah this is eight
it's crazy because if you think of Terry
Crews you only ever see him in like a
comedic form do you know what I mean and
it's crazy that that that's just genuine
just general acting yeah like that that
might not even be his demeanor he might
not be he could be but you only ever see
him act in a certain manner he's kind of
almost Typecast did you know yeah oh 100
time costed and it's it's crazy man it's
just crazy well how
you you can see someone in a movie
series whatever for many years and you
just think oh this is just how he is
normally you know but
okay no he's a little sweetheart clearly
not man
um right you want to finish off with a
question for everyone yes I do and you
said you finished the glory right yeah
gangs I can ask you so
um you're not gonna watch The Glory
right Ram
um no even if you do you're not even
gonna remember yeah 16 long ass episodes
anyway it is a long series it's a long
Series yeah good though it was great
yeah very very good I've already got one
next one to add it to my list
um
okay ultimatum right
would you if you were
if you were not Eugene's okay Eugene's
husband not her husband but the the real
dad
J John or whatever yeah
if you were Jade Jun
in his current situation he [__] by the
way in the show
he claps
um in his current situation and you had
the same altercation with
husband in that face-to-face meet in the
parking lot in the park
prior to the parking lot when he came to
the golf club yes something like that
yeah yeah so would you a
divorce your killer wife and give up the
right so this is you saying it to the
husband divorce your killer wife and
give up the rights to your daughter
um to be the biological father or he
leaks all the evidence with a voice
recording of the death
I'm the husband you're the husband yes
and Jason's just threatened me with this
yeah what would you do so would you
rather give up your because he's not
your daughter but she is your daughter
yeah with ratings the way he writes for
his daughter and that yeah he does yeah
who who are you talking about by the way
the the husband oh yeah of course yeah I
would too the [__] yeah yeah of course I
would
um yeah so would you divorce your missus
who you've actually now found out is an
actual stone cold killer yeah yeah and
give up your rights to your daughter or
a legal evidence about your wife which
would then probably implicate you
because you man are married anyway and
we're just going to lose our daughter
anyway you're going to lose which one
are you going to do
um so for context for people who have
not watched this show yeah sorry so what
we're talking about is I am
um in this scenario I am do young yeah I
am a CEO of a major corporation or a
billionaire long story short I'm married
to
um Eugene yeah who is a weather cast
girl and she is
um the main antagonist the main
antagonist and she's a murderer she's a
murderer and a bully a bully and a
murderer she's my wife and I have no
idea about this and then the guy
threatening me is Jay June who is my
wife's side man
and
um the biological father of my daughter
so in this scenario's asking me yeah
the the
this guy is now telling me to my face I
am your wife's side man I am your
daughter's real father
your wife is a murderer
hold that information
and here's your two things I have
evidence that your wife is a murderer
which I will leak
and will probably implicate yourself
and she's definitely going to prison or
all you need to do is divorce her
would you want to anyway because you
just I've just told you she's a murderer
and a cheat
um but when you divorce her I need you
to relinquish your parental rights to
your daughter and she comes to me yeah
leak it
I swear 100 I swear as soon as he's
telling me I'd I'd hear him out yeah
until he says relinquish your parental
rights knowing that he's talking about
because the door's going to go to him
I'll say leak what you want to leak big
man
Over My Dead Body are you taking this
you fair enough because I love this
child fair enough fair enough she loves
me and she oh that's the main important
piece yeah she loves me and she's scared
of you facts because you're threatening
facts yeah you're scaring you're
threatening my guy so I would say leak
whatever you want to leak bro fair
enough you're not taking her that's just
let's literally no scenario where you're
taking this year Over My Dead Body okay
cool fair fair I'd obviously do the same
thing I would just I'll just asking
that's a good question though that was a
oh he put how do young deal dealt with
that he dealt with it from four episodes
he was so composed I suppose for months
composed for months yeah he was burning
inside I don't know how he handled it
neither do I he ended a man though when
push came to Sharp literally yeah
literally he doesn't forget nothing that
was that was sick wow yeah damn bro yeah
man really really really really really
really really really good series but
yeah good question yeah but okay cool
man thank you for today guys that was
decent uh we're gonna wrap it there
um please join us on Thursday at
patreon.com
without any further Ado level of love
[Music]
foreign